what you feel if you've seen bolt
something identified as a woman that's a
ridiculous question oh and you know
I'll wake up tomorrow morning and decide
that you're a woman and start
Ed
it takes two years in the UK it takes
two years it takes one year to qualify
as Athletics right okay so Usain Bolt
could could potentially within a year
with a bit of reduced testosterone
treatment it could Sprint against women
a huge reduction in testosterone yeah it
makes no difference to body mass or size
or power but it would be it would it
would alter everything so you'd be fun
would you be fine with that if he
suddenly didn't if that's if respect his
right to be a woman yes it's not
particular it is ridiculous but not for
the reasons you think but because it
could happen and you think it's fair
that's obscene that is obscene would you
be happy if you've seen both identified
as a woman and began winning the race an
argument out of what are people's lives
it's happening with Leah Thomas